what's going on guys this is Rob and
Marvel has officially launched his first
black panther title in the Ultimate
Universe and this story is amazing so
what this does is this picks up in West
Africa and right off the bat all these
people who were there are eradicated by
these soldiers in the names of raw and
konu now one of the things that I also
want to specify here is that this is the
Ultimate Universe this is not the main
Marvel universe so konu is not actually
appear in the form of a god instead it
is just a guy who uses the name konu and
another guy who uses the name raw and
that's really all there is keep in mind
these guys are part of basically a giant
inner Council the Illuminati if you want
to call it that that run the world and
they're making their move to conquer
their respective countries so the entire
continent of Africa falls under the rule
of raw and konu and so what you have
while this goes down is you have these
two wakand spies who were watching
everything happen as these people are
rounded up or they're eradicated
eliminated whatever the case is and
these guys in witnessing all of this
they say come brother we have seen
enough yet we have done nothing their
time will come brother we have seen the
anger of raw and konu soon they will
know the justice of wakanda now at that
point you pick up with black panther now
here's the other thing for those of you
guys who are not caught up you'll find a
link to the playlist at the end of this
video in effect right like the maker
basically an evil alternate version of
Reed Richards had gone to an alternate
universe this particular universe that
we're in here and basically change the
past so that superheroes never came into
existence in their traditional way and
so they're all kind of coming into
existence in their own new ways hence
the reason why you're going to see some
big differences here one of the biggest
differences from the main Marvel
universe is that black panther is not
married to storm instead he's married to
to AOE which I'm going to be honest with
you guys I never knew I needed this I
think these guys are like a perfect
couple it makes perfect sense especially
thinking about the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and the MCU it just works right
I love the idea but the other thing is
that much like the MCU AO was at one
point the general of the Dora mhe but in
marrying black panther she's not really
playing that role anymore now she's
really the high Mentor for the Dora mhe
but because Trad tradtion and everything
still reign supreme in wakanda right
because what is a king if not a subject
to tradition the two of them don't
actually share the same bet so there's
huge differences here right like one of
the things he even goes so far as to say
is that Traditions must change and so
one of the coolest things that goes on
here is that you have him basically
meeting with his father right tachaka is
still very much alive and one of the
things that happens is that as the two
of them converse with one another it
really is kind of the more more
Progressive Viewpoint versus the more
traditional Viewpoint and that's one of
the things that's really being borrowed
here from the Marvel Cinematic Universe
the reality is that tachaka did play a
role in the early black panther stories
specifically from the old jungle action
series really the first major series
that involved a black character in
Marvel Comics but the kind of depth that
you saw in later stories involving the
relationship between tala and his father
that didn't really even deal with things
on the same level that this does right
even during Jonathan Hickman's Avengers
and New Avengers right when he spoke
with his father and his father was
giving him wisdom and so on and so forth
this just feels wholly different here
and the reason is that as they go back
and forth his father asks it's early are
you still plagued with dreams the
response of tchala they are only dreams
father he responds they are the brutal
dreams of a king perhaps the gods speak
to you perhaps you are plagued because
you will not listen the response of tala
perhaps the gods should make their
wishes more clear so one of the cool
things to notice here is that because
tachaka is still very much rooted in
Tradition the idea of the Gods speaking
to them is still very much a part of his
belief system for someone like tala that
just kind of seems old hat now the other
cool thing is that you're not really
going to see Bast here per se but
because this is the Ultimate Universe I
would go so far as to say Bast is like
the panther God in the traditional sense
that you're used to in the main Marvel
universe that's probably not going to
happen here either only time will tell
but there is a character that's going to
pop up here that's going to blow your
mind now one of the things that happens
is his father says speak with the
designed mother of the vodu Khan she
wants your counsel of course he responds
in saying she wants my servitude to her
signs importance I do not trust them or
her ways again hitting on this idea this
is all old hat right these priests who
speak for the gods and I should listen
to their prophecies and govern my
country based on super ition right that
kind of thing it's just one of those
Concepts where you just kind of like no
right this is just sort of all
nonsensical stuff and the only reason I
follow it is just because of tradition
but I want nothing more than to cast it
all aside but the big issue here is that
tala rules a nation of people if he were
to start casting aside Traditions
indiscriminately it could lead to his
people revolting against him so again
like the role of a king is just as much
managing expectations as it is living
and ruling your kingdom in a way that
you see fit and so the results of all
that is that he ends up traveling to the
Temple of the vodu Kon now what is
really interesting here is that the idea
of the vodu that is actually being
borrowed from the main Marvel Universe
but the reality here is that outside of
Lorna the Jungle Queen right the old
1950s comic and the old 1950s jungle
Tales Comics as well as like maybe some
entries into the Marvel handbook I'm not
100% sure about that there isn't really
a whole lot of reference to those guys
but the important thing is that in the
main Marvel Universe the vodu are like
these other-dimensional gods of West
Africa not that dissimilar from like
Bast or you could even potentially look
at them as some variation of like
eternals that belong to the African
continent but it is still borrowing the
concept of gods and placing them here
but notice you don't actually see them
instead it is someone speaking on their
behalf so again very much grounded very
much realistic which was always the
nature of the ultim universe and so even
for tala when he shows up here it's
frustrating right like this just priest
of the vodu Khan is like you dream of
Pain King tchala suffering and what does
that teach you his response I learn from
books not dreams their response is you
underestimate dreams King tchala and his
response and the vodon underestimates me
I am not my father and of course they
fire back and they say since the birth
of wakanda the vodu has served this
Kingdom and all of its Kings our
connection to the gods is yours allow me
to prove that by offering you counsel my
king and so again it's just very much
hearsay right just it seems very
nonsensical and of course matron imala
the speaker of the God says in
meditation we have sensed a violent
becoming enemies in our midst enemies
outside of the walls trust no one my
king your dreams warn you the gods are
on your side but Gods can be fickle and
that's when he fires back and he says I
won't be paralyzed by paranoia matron I
will not rule in fear of my own people
and so that's when he is given a pretty
solid bit of advice here where he's told
do not choose fear choose awareness we
will be your eyes as well and so it's
one of those things where it's kind of
like okay like yes you don't really
believe in any of this Superstition you
know all that kind of stuff what have
you at the very least H comfort in the
fact that like we are everywhere and we
are nowhere so any information that we
see we will give you now to those two
spies that we saw at the beginning of
the comic they show up here and they
tell chachala exactly what they saw and
what you get is really like almost this
perfect kind of adaptation for something
that you would see in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe in the sense that
what they say is that when it comes to
these soldiers moving across Africa as a
continent they're attacking village
after Village right they're going after
all these different groups they're
either enslaving them or they're
slaughtering them but in effect they're
attacking Africa as a continent and they
almost kind of bear this sort of
subliminal warning where they're like
you know be careful King tala it's only
a matter of time before they come for us
and so shuri takes it that way and in
fact shu's not Queen at the moment right
of course you know she's basically just
the sister of black panther but she is
the genius here now that's one of the
big differences between the main Marvel
Universe version of Shu and this version
of Shu in the Ultimate Universe of
course this one's designed to bring her
more in line with the MCU to kind of
copy what the Marvel Cinematic Universe
is doing but in the main Marvel universe
shuri is not a technological genius
right she's a really really awesome
Queen she's an amazing black panther but
she is not any kind of a technological
genius certainly nowhere near what she
is in the MCU this version here is and
so this is the reason why if you love
the Black Panther Mythos in the Marvel
catic Universe this is the comic for you
not the Black Panther comic in the main
Marvel Universe and so the thing here is
that she's basically kind of makes this
argument we need to go to war we have to
go to war and we have to attack these
forces head on but tala is a lot more
wise than his sister is and I would
argue a lot more experienced here
because she keeps thinking that what
he's saying is well we're not going to
do anything right he's like we're not
going to enter into a war and she's like
well father would act right and he's
just like father is not King here and I
did not say that we would not act The
Stance of tchala is we need information
if we just go charging headlong into a
war against enemies that we don't
understand we almost guarantee our loss
what are their capabilities what are
they hunting for what are their measures
and what could our counter measures be
right just charging headlong into a
conflict yeah that's almost guaranteed
destruction but sh is very young and
very fiery for her it's more about just
we need to get out there and protect our
people it doesn't mean to say that she's
foolish it doesn't mean to say that she
is an idiot or she's thinking like a
no no no no her compassion for
really the people in Africa as a
continent is really what governs her
here and so the result of all this at
the end of the day is AO takes the side
of tchala in genuinely agreeing with
what he's saying we need to understand
the foe that we are facing before we
jump into a conflict less we guarantee
our own destruction and Shri essentially
just storms off now what you end up
getting is shuri who actually ends up
meeting directly with abeni who is in
effect the leader of the DOR mhe at this
point in time but one of the things that
had gone on between the conversation of
AO and black panther after Shu had left
was that the DOR mhe they want war and
they want to use shu's intelligence to
do it so that's one of the cool
differences here is that we're kind of
getting this image this picture that yes
the DOR mhe are loyal a black panther
but they're also soldiers and as AO
points out a soldier serves no purpose
in a time of peace right that's the
reason why books like hagakure exists in
the first place right just this really
old school book that exists here in the
world world that gives an answer to the
samurai here's what your purposes when
there is no wartime conflict going on no
purpose for you on an individual level
that's kind of what the Doral seem to be
struggling with there's no war and in
the absence of War what's their point
they sit around all day twigling their
thumbs or playing cards right so they're
always hankering and Desiring for some
kind of conflict with shuri being the
sister of black panther she has his ear
better than any member of the D mhe ever
possibly could outside of AOE and so
using shuri the goal is to go to Black
Panther into a war and in fact the way
this ends is going to be really really
interesting because I'm curious to see
how you guys interpret it and so what
shuri is told is use your mind right if
you're so frustrated by everything going
on use your mind and build us something
beautiful right some kind of a deadly
weapon and that's when you switch back
over to another part of West Africa
we're not really given a particular
country or anything like that but you
end up getting these soldiers who show
up yet again and go to attack the people
in this West African territory the
kicker about all this is that a guy
appears out of nowhere right who looks
amazing like brandishing this this
Hatchet and just starts chopping these
guys to pieces he saves this kid and
he's just like go hide more are coming
and so as these forces show up he says
my love bless them and like this force
shows up out of nowhere lightning comes
down strikes these soldiers destroys the
ship this guy finishes off the rest and
then he tells everybody here he says
people of this Village and I love the
way this happens because I can almost
guarantee you guys already know what's
going on here this guy says people of
this Village your gods and Hidden
Kingdoms will not protect you but
killmonger and the wind rider will and
so in effect of course this is Eric
kilmonger but it also looks like storm
so like that would be nuts if Eric
kilmonger and storm were like a couple
or married or something like that but
this is the ending that I was telling
you guys about this is where it goes
nuts because you basically have wakanda
and the annual celebration of life and
tala makes this grandiose speech he says
today is the celebration of life today
we rejoice in the love we have for one
another this is our Kingdom built from
the efforts of each and every one of you
it is my honor to serve as your king You
Are My Strength you are my family you
are my faith you are my legacy only for
us to find out that this priest who is
here standing with him ends up basically
revealing all these explosives tied to
her chest she shouts for konu for raah
detonates herself tachaka himself is
killed in the process black panther
immediately Dawn the outfit before he
hits the ground and he just tells
everybody get the queen get my sister
and the vodu KH our enemy calls
themselves moonnight wakanda is at War
it it's an amazing start to the Black
Panther comic with that being said guys
we're going to bring this to an end let
me know what you think down in the
comments section if you need to get
caught up make sure you click this link
to the playlist and I will catch you all
later peace